da bambini
crediamo tutti di poter costruire il
nostro futuro di poter seguire i nostri
sogni e di diventare tutto quello che
vogliamo diventare le statistiche i
numeri purtroppo ci raccontano un'altra
storia ci dicono che molti di voi molti
di noi vivono un futuro predeterminato
vivono una storia che è già scritta da
quando sono bambini
io sono qui per raccontarvi questa
storia perché è stata la storia di
troppi della mia generazione e non
voglio che sia la stessa storia per i
bambini di oggi e per i bambini di
domani partiamo proprio da qui dai
bambini
immaginate di due bambini francesca e
paolo
entrambi hanno sei anni
francesca vive in centro a milano i
genitori sono laureati paolo vive in
periferia e genitori non hanno finito le
scuole superiori
francesca fa sport
già la classe di musica e già sta
imparando l'inglese i suoi genitori sono
talmente fissati sulla sua istruzione
che nei prossimi anni si convinceranno
di fare tutto quello che possono
affinché lei possa andare in una scuola
buona affinché farà i compiti e
parteciperanno a tutti gli incontri dei
con gli insegnanti con i professori e
genitori di paolo sono distratti
impegnati stressati non lo seguono e non
credono che l'istruzione possa fare
vento la differenza su di lui tanto non
è poi così intelligente quindi per lui
niente inglese niente musica poco sport
francesca e paolo come tutti i bambini
di sei anni in realtà sono i denti si
amano giocare a palla a mano di segnare
entrambi vogliono fare l'astronauta
quando crescono
purtroppo le loro storie sono molto
diverse e avranno dei futuri molto
diversi tra loro sono come due treni su
due binari paralleli che pro vanno in
direzioni completamente opposte
francesca andrà al liceo si iscriverà
all'università
diventerà un avvocato un architetto
ingegnere
paolo lascerà la scuola prima di finire
la scuola superiore e passerà a tutti i
20 anni e 30 anni da disoccupato
anzi c'è un termine scientifico per
descrivere paolo sarà un meet così in
inglese si descrivono quei giovani che
non studiano non lavorano e non si
formano neanche per trovare un altro
lavoro e in italia i neet sono un
esercito in alcuni in alcune regioni
sono più del 30 per cento dei giovani
sotto i 30 anni quindi un terzo dei
nostri giovani che ha seduto sul divano
e che guarda la vita che gli passa
davanti senza però le competenze la
visione e l'attitudine per poter
affrontare un mondo che in continuo
cambiamento e che continua a essere
sempre più difficile
allora io mi chiedo vi chiedo possiamo
come paese come società permetterci una
tale perdita di talenti e di risorse
umane chiaramente la risposta è no la
realtà è che in italia oggi paolo aveva
solamente dalla nascita aveva solamente
l'otto per cento di possibilità di
finire l'università mentre francesca ne
arriva il 70 per cento perché la realtà
è che viviamo in un paese in cui le tue
è la tua condizione socio economica il
tuo livello di istruzione dei tuoi
genitori il quartiere da cui proviene e
dove vivi e la scuola che scegli
determineranno il tuo futuro è il tuo
livello di istruzione
un paese in cui la scuola pubblica dopo
decenni di daisy 20 disinvestimenti
decenni di disinteresse generale e
soprattutto di mancate riforme non ce la
fa più a colmare le diseguaglianze
educative le diseguaglianze strutturali
che esistono nel nostro paese un paese
che già prima del covip penso che siete
tutti stanchi da un anno e mezzo di
leggere di dat non da digitale non
digitale di tutti i ragazzi lasciati a
se stessi già prima di due anni di crisi
covip l'italia era un paese che soffriva
alcune tra le più alte diseguaglianze
educative d'europa non solo per i
bambini come paolo che non finiscono ma
per anche per tutti coloro che la
finiscono pensate il 40 per cento di che
finisce le scuole superiori in italia
non riesce a comprendere un testo il 50
per cento di chi si diploma non ha le
competenze basi in matematica è una vera
e propria crisi educativa nazionale
ora le storie di paolo di francesca sono
degli esempi generali potete cambiare il
nome la città
il contesto della famiglia però
rappresentano milioni di italiani
milioni di vita di milioni di italiani
inclusa la mia va p sono qui a
raccontarvi questa storia perché io
dovevo essere paolo io vengo dalla
famiglia umile i miei genitori non sono
laureati e prima di andare in pensione
pochi anni fa erano dei piccoli
commercianti e io ero destinato a
lavorare nel negozio con loro
niente di male avrei avuto una
bellissima vita adoro i miei genitori il
loro a loro nome ha ragionato il negozio
però quello era il mio destino
avevo un futuro predeterminato ma io a
differenza di paolo ho avuto due
elementi che mi hanno cambiato la vita
che hanno permesso al mio treno di
deragliare da quei binari verso quel
futuro predeterminato e di andare da
un'altra parte molto lontano dal negozio
dei miei genitori mi hanno portato a
fare ricerca in africa a lavorare a
londra a new york e poi in cina sono
stato come milioni di italiani uno di
quegli italiani all'estero per 16 anni e
come milioni di italiani all'estero
tornava in italia ogni anno perché a
natale estate da ritornare e trovavo un
paese diverso da quello che avevo
lasciato un paese più povero a livello
economico ma anche più povero a livello
culturale e non lo accettavo un paese
imbruttito arrabbiato scontento e volevo
cambiare le cose e quindi ho riflettuto
soprattutto perché vedevo che le storie
di paolo continuavano a replicarsi c'è
una cosa troppi paolo continuavano a
crescere paolo in questo paese e allora
ho pensato cos'è che ha portato il mio
treno a deragliare e sono stati due
fattori il primo interno i miei genitori
che ringrazio ringrazio sempre perché mi
hanno donato la libertà più grande che è
quella di credere che ce l'avrei potuto
fare e che avrei potuto fare qualsiasi
cosa e nonostante i pochi soldi e le
poche risorse mi ricordo ancora i mesi
in cui non sapevano se potevano pagare
il mutuo
l'attenzione di quegli anni i soldi per
la mia istruzione c'erano sempre e
quindi li ringrazio ancora ma il secondo
fattore il fa con il secondo elemento
che mi ha cambiato la vita è un evento
esterno del cuore di questa storia è la
mia maestra delle elementari
ancora me la ricordo
dolce umile steve era quando doveva
essere severa ma anche piena di amore è
stata la prima persona fuori dalla mia
famiglia a credere in me ea credere
nelle mie potenzialità e facendolo mi ha
cambiato la vita io ero un bambino
timido e insicuro un po pigro non un
genio non lo sarò mai stato non lo sarò
mai però ero curioso e lei ha preso
questa mia curiosità e ci ha lavorato e
mi ha aperto il mondo le volevamo tutti
bene le volevo bene anch'io e tant'è che
ci ha invitato al suo matrimonio in
chiesa quel giorno era pieno di tutti i
bambini a cui la insediava quindi era
una chiesa piena di bambini piene di
colori chiana di amore e solo qualche
anno fa mi sono reso conto quanto
quell'amore di quella maestra mi sa che
mi ha cambiato la vita ma non è un caso
la scienza ci dice ci prova che già a 7
anni i bambini iniziano a costruire il
loro senso del mondo e il loro senso di
se stessi e iniziano a percepire quali
possono essere le loro potenzialità
cosa possono veramente fare della vita e
allora mi sono chiesto se non posso fare
in modo che tutti i bambini italiani
abbiano i miei genitori oi genitori
comunque come i miei che mi hanno
seguito supportato forse possa fare
qualcosa affinché tutti i bambini
italiani abbiamo la mia maestra o
abbiano una maestra che come lei abbia
cambiato la vita che abbiano
un'esperienza da scuola trasformativa
per loro per le loro famiglie e forse un
giorno per tutto il paese e allora con
un gruppo di persone che come me crede
che per cambiare l'italia si debba
partire da sbloccare quello che
chiamiamo il diritto alle opportunità
abbiamo fondato teach for italy che
un'organizzazione che si occupa di
lavorare sulle diseguaglianze educative
l'idea è molto semplice crediamo che
tutti i migliori talenti italiani
possano e debbano scegliere di insegnare
magari non per tutta la vita magari lo
fanno per qualche anno ma crediamo che
se tu hai avuto fortuna o sei stato
particolarmente bravo e tu dover e poter
aiutare chi parte più svantaggiato e
quindi selezioniamo i migliori neo
laureati e giovani professionisti anche
italiani che magari fanno un lavoro che
non gli piace più ma che sono guidati da
una passione per cambiare il paese e da
una passione per la giustizia sociale e
li inseriamo né un programma di due anni
volto a trasformarli in insegnanti
trasformativi li inseriamo nelle scuole
più svantaggiate del paese dove per due
anni di seguito in questa esperienza di
docenti e vogliamo che abbiano un
impatto sistemico in quelle classi in
quelle scuole ma in tutte le comunità in
cui lavorano mentre fra l'altro fanno
un'esperienza personale e di dita di
crescita stupenda da un lato quindi
vogliamo migliorare la scuola pubblica
italiana nei contesti più svantaggiati
inserendo magari talenti che non è vero
non avrebbero pensato all'insegnamento
senza di noi o coloro che magari
volevano già insegnare ma aiutandole
diventare degli insegnanti migliori e
facendolo partendo dai posti più
svantaggiati
dall'altro però non ci basta questo
quello che vogliamo fare trasformare
l'eco sistema educativo italiano e per
farlo non vogliamo solamente bravi
insegnanti
vogliamo dei veri e propri agenti del
cambiamento che negli anni rimarranno
all'interno del sistema e lo cambieranno
quindi vogliamo che i nostri ragazzi
diventino rimangano chiaramente
insegnanti ma diventino dirigenti
scolastici i provveditori
finiscano per lavorare al ministero
lavorino per centri di ricerca per il
terzo settore magari nelle startup
educative ma che pian piano nei prossimi
anni costruiscano un movimento nato dal
basso partito dalle classi delle scuole
chiuse vantaggiato nel paese che porti
avanti una visione diversa di scuola una
visione più equa più inclusiva più
innovativa ora mi dite mi sono imposti
con sei un pazzo è stato duro però ce
l'abbiamo fatta e prendiamo ad esempio
esempi di cambiamento in 60 altri paesi
del mondo dove questi programmi già
esistono e stanno cambiando la vita a
milioni di studenti di famiglie che in
paesi diversi dall'india alla gran
bretagna dal cile all'argentina e in
questi paesi per esempio in green e
stati uniti dove questo programma è
partito trent'anni fa quando sono
partiti i distretti scolastici di
washington di detroit erano tra i
peggiori di quel paese e anno dopo anno
scuola doposcuola l'abbandono scolastico
e crollato i risultati didattici sono
aumentati a londra in 15 anni hanno
raddoppiato la percentuale di studenti
svantaggiati che non solo si iscrive
all'università ma che finisce
l'università ma la cosa più bella è che
tutte queste persone poi rimangono nel
sistema e diventano con gli attori del
cambiamento negli ultimi due anni li
abbiamo visti trasformare il digitale
costruire delle organizzazioni che
proprio lavoravano sull'accesso al
digitale per quegli studenti che non
avevano accesso durante il covip oppure
alcune addirittura entrano in politica
per dedicarsi solamente dell'istruzione
perché in tutti i nostri paesi è una
delle cose di cui la politica si occupa
di meno
sono tutte storie di cambiamento unite
da una cosa dall'idea di una leadership
collettiva di persone che scelgono
l'insegnamento per avere un impatto
sociale in fondo nelson mandela ci
ricordava che l'istruzione è la l'arma
migliore forse l'unica arma che abbiamo
per cambiare il mondo e quindi vi chiedo
che ruolo volete avere in questo
movimento che ruolo volete avere in
questo cambiamento perché abbiamo
bisogno di tutti voi
ognuno di voi può giocare un ruolo da
indipendente da persona si da familiare
di qualcuno da dipendente di un'azienda
coinvolgendo l'azienda da dipendente
pubblico trasformando quell'ufficio
abbiamo bisogno di un movimento
nazionale che trasformi questo paese in
un paese che non si dimentichi 30 per
cento dei suoi giovani per strada un
paese senza futuro i predestinati è un
paese in cui paolo e francesca potranno
un giorno avere le stesse opportunità
per costruire per loro stesse per tutti
noi un futuro migliore grazie
[Applauso]